greatness comes from adversity and  looking the challenge in the eye and  having the intestinal fortitude to step  up and go after it but it's just making  every [ __ ] minute  count every minute has to count every  minute past account if you want so much  because you just don't have as many of  them as you think you just don't and so  you got to put in the work you want  muscles you've got to actually do the  the weight you've got to actually put in  the work you want a business there is no  shortcut so the progress who made and  you made over the last five ten twelve  years and your fitness is exactly the  same thing that's gonna happen in  business there is no overnight success  there is no one year you've done it well  and now you have the biggest business  it's day in and day I've been an  entrepreneur since I was eight I'm 40  now that's 32 years of practice now you  just have to really do it doesn't happen